first of all you said you were a really
big part of
getting the show off the ground what
does it feel like to be back for a
second season
you know it was so great to be back for
a second season i think that we've all
gotten to know each other a lot better
so the dynamics have definitely gotten
better and improved and the fact that
there's more depth and dimension but
it's exciting to see
you know such a spotlight on salt lake
city and park city too
yes for sure did you get any advice from
any other of the housewives in any other
cities
you know so many women so many women
have reached out one of the first reach
out was dolores from new jersey she's so
sweet and you know just being originally
from new york i tend to gravitate to you
know the east coast girls and franchises
and she was like just be yourself um
lisa renna has been amazing i think that
she's great
she is fabulous and she's so positive
like whenever she sends a dm it's like
super positive and uplifting and you
know i had i got to have dinner with
karen huger a few weeks ago and she gave
me some great advice too just um as her
season's evolved and i think their
franchise is kind of similar to salt
lake in so many ways so i love that she
was willing to offer up some advice and
she's a lot of fun to hang out with too
i mean lisa rena's dance moves can we
just for a second on her instagram
oh my gosh she's the best seriously i
lisa rana's instagram is my favorite
because she's just it's like what she's
feeling which she's thinking you spray
and like i feel like we all think we're
lisa rena's bestie
you're absolutely right i'm i'm uh at a
at a cottage right now which is not far
from lisa rena's cottage here and i feel
like i'm just like come over we'll have
ketchup chips together like come here
because she's so great i love it i bet
she would
you probably would yeah um listen i saw
the trailer this is a season this is a
season that is something else
it was intense it was intense from day
one there was never a dull moment i
think we i think we were going to have a
seller's
season like one month into filming and
and then as it progressed it got more
and more intense and
yeah
boy did it i mean we see you get in the
middle of some rumors about mary's
church
what made you believe there may be
that there may be something going on
there you know i've never
you know on social media there's so much
stuff about mary's church and i've never
gone down the rabbit hole i just don't
do that with my friends and with people
i'm friendly with um that's just not my
personal style
we all know mary um because my friend
cameron introduced mary to the group and
karen's always been
super kind amazing and you know he lets
people formulate their own opinions he
didn't share any of his thoughts or
feelings and then after you know
some other things happened you know you
kind of think like how well do i really
know
anybody and so i think you know cameron
had
shared some experiences with me and
you know i just wanted to ask him his
opinion on some things and get his take
and um his feelings so i think it was
i think that um
[Music]
how do i want to phrase this
i think it's good to get to know who
you're in who you're friends with
that's fair enough i think that's a good
way to say it for sure now listen there
is also
a lot of coverage around uh jen's
situation um how does her legal
situation you know really impact the
dynamic of the group
so jen has been a trooper and since you
know all the all the things happened
um she has still she still showed up for
events she still showed up and filmed
with all of us and she was still very
present you know jen's circumstances
don't change who i am as a person um
whatever type of friend i was to jen
before her legal situation is the exact
type of friend i'm gonna be after um and
that's never changed um how i treat
anyone and i just think it's tough i
mean jen has a hard fight that she
has to go like i mean jen's fighting a
hard fight right now and you know we all
want the best for her and are hoping for
the best for jen in her situation yeah
for sure there's a new housewife joining
this season what advice do you have for
jenny this season um
what advice do i have for jenny um
oh my gosh there's so much advice
um i just think the best thing you can
do is just be a hundred percent yourself
and if you're honest about who you are
you can't fail like i
you know
lots of people like to weigh in on how
season one was for me but the one thing
i can always say is i was 100 me and if
you're yourself you can speak to
anything answer you don't have to worry
about having receipts it's you just have
to be yourself
no absolutely i mean last year listen we
did see some tension between you and
heather where do you two stand now
um i'm good with everybody i think i
think um you know heather and i um can
agree to disagree on certain things and
i think that you know by the end of the
season and at the reunion you got to see
you know there is a time to bring out
like receipts and facts and i brought
those out and it was like listen i
didn't lie about when i met heather i
didn't have why would i do that and i
think that um
as people are going through different
phases of their life and experiencing
different things i think that you evolve
and i think that heather and my
relationship has definitely evolved
right they're seeing how they're
stealing on me still though yeah yeah
that's right there's always a season
right all right we know you are a fan of
fast food so what is the one fast food
that has gotten you through this last
year and a half
you know i i have to say it's always
going to be taco bell
it's i literally it's easy fast go-to i
know i'm not i know i like it
um but you know i'm i'm still love i
still love my diet coke and my taco bell
i mean i do have an amazing palette for
luxury eats too
so i am balanced you are balanced i love
that i'm balanced my taco bell my luxury
eats that's true
okay but something else that you love we
have this in common
is tequila so my question is when will
vita tequila be here in canada because
i love this
you know
canada is very similar to utah with like
how you get into the
um the what is it called it's not states
it's well basically the country did we
get into our provinces yes your
provinces and so we had an amazing
meeting with
um your liquor some people from your
liquor board and i think that vita will
be in canada very soon and we're so
excited about it i don't know if you
know this but my brother-in-law and
sister-in-law both my brother and sister
married canadians so we have a big love
of canada and i spent so many summers in
montreal
and
and we love love canada so i'm so
excited to be able to have our liquor
there
okay well i will be looking for it
because i'm a tequila girl so
well thank you so much for taking the
time today all the best of luck and be
well
thank you you too thank you
you